when polls show that 9 out of 10
Americans want something whatever it is
you'd think that would get the immediate
attention of the political class in this
country after all 90 percent of
Americans don't support more funding for
Ukraine or punting on the debt ceiling
or you know hanging Pride flags on our
embassies and yet in a representative
democracy the leaders of both major
parties are on board with all those
things so whatever the standard for
bipartisan urgency is it's a lot less
than 90 percent in the polls with that
in mind it's more than a little bit
strange that for decades nine out of 10
Americans virtually the entire country
really wanted something that our
political leaders barely ever talked
about pulling from Gallup has measured
this they found that from 1990 to 2013
the percentage of people in this country
who wanted children had remained at the
same extremely high level quote
Americans attitudes about having
children have remained unchanged over
the past 23 years more than 9 in 10
adults say they already have children or
planning to have children or wish that
they had had children
the five percent of Americans who do not
want children is virtually the same as
the four percent found in Gallup found
in 1990. that was Gallup that was a
decade ago
now reading that you'd think that every
politician would have spent the last 30
years making sure that people could have
the families they clearly wanted to have
you'd think they'd have paid attention
to fertility rates for example and stay
on top of any downward Trend in the
birth rate and yet as Americans clearly
expressed their preference for having
kids politicians and health experts
totally ignored a problem that would
prevent many young men from ever
becoming fathers starting decades ago
testosterone levels in young men began
declining rapidly at a rate never before
seen in human history and without any
explanation
this is another thing that you would
think if you were naive anyway you would
think our political leaders would take
note of
when something is happening in society
that has never happened before
we should focus on it and we should try
to figure out why it's happening
when for instance LGBT identities are
rising exponentially seemingly out of
nowhere reaching levels in the
population never before seen or when a
when as mentioned testosterone levels
are falling through the floor all this
is historic and so we should look at it
and say what is going on here
on that latter point about testosterone
here's the data the journal of clinical
endocrinology and Metabolism found that
by 2006 testosterone levels in men had
decreased by more than 20 percent since
the mid-1980s which is a staggering job
the authors couldn't identify any reason
for the drop quote we observe a
substantial age-dependent independent
decline in t that does not appear to be
attributable to observed changes and
explanatory factors including health and
lifestyle characteristics such as
smoking and obesity the author's added
quote it remains unclear to what these
apparent population level decreases in t
are attributable
without any real interest from anyone in
the public health field the problem got
much worse over time in 2020 the journal
European Urology found that average
testosterone levels had dropped by
approximately 25 since 1999. the
researchers found that quote
testosterone deficiency has a prevalence
of 20 among Adolescent and young adult
males and that again there was no clear
explanation
now because people were getting a lot
fatter in this period and still are a
lot of media reports speculated there
was a causal connection there since
obesity tends to lower testosterone
levels but the researchers again
determined that that was not the cause
of the problem quote the trend remains
significant even among men with normal
BMI
as a consequence of this crisis which
has metastasized more men than ever in
this country are suffering from a series
of debilitating disorders that undermine
and in some cases eliminate their
reproductive Fitness so we're talking
about problems like less bone density
less muscle mass more chronic disease
erectile dysfunction low sperm count
just to name a few
we're seeing a dramatic increase in all
of these problems right now sperm counts
in particular have fallen off a cliff
watch
we turn now to male infertility it is an
Affliction that many struggle with in
silence and we could be headed toward a
crisis researchers have found that male
sperm count has plummeted by 50 since
the 1970s but why ABC's Trevor alt has
this report Dr Shanna Swann is an
environmental and reproductive
epidemiologist the author of countdown
how our modern world is threatening
sperm counts altering male and female
reproductive development and imperiling
the future of the human race her team
collected and analyzed nearly 200
studies of more than 40 000 men and they
found in Western countries from 1973 to
2011 the average sperm count decreased
from 99 million per milliliter to 47
million a drop of more than 50 percent
and a pay set if it were to continue
could have an enormous impact is that as
alarming as it would seem to be it's
very alarming sounds like a lot of sperm
47 million
alarming yeah I mean the title of the
book says it's imperiling the future of
the human race which it is
I mean these are the kinds of problems
that are rarely talked about especially
among the political class
and yet the future of humanity actually
hangs in the balance
sperm counts are down and with it so is
libido a recent Pew study found that 63
percent of men under the age of 30 are
single now for comparison just a few
years ago in 2019 that number was 51 so
it was very high back then just a few
years ago and now it's even higher and
these are post covet numbers from Pew
also so this isn't because of social
distancing or whatever millions of young
men don't want to date or at least uh
they aren't dating even if they want to
the relatively few men who are dating
and getting married are now doing it
much later in life according to the Wall
Street Journal from 1990 to 2019 the
percentage of people who get married in
middle age has increased by nearly 75
percent for women and 45 for men
consequences are what you'd expect when
people get married later in life as
their fertility declines
birth rates drop and they have in the
1970s the average number of children
born per one in the United States was
three
now that average number is less than two
in fact in 2021 the birth rate was just
1.6 births per woman
which is half of what it was in the
1950s now that is well below replacement
level meaning if this trend continues
indefinitely the U.S population will
eventually die out completely
the only reason that overall population
numbers are holding steady in this
country is due to immigration the native
U.S population in this country is dying
out and being replaced by people
imported from other parts of the world
in a world filled with uncertainties
it's crucial to be ready for whatever
comes your way whether it's a natural
disaster a sudden emergency or
unforeseen circumstances having a
reliable food storage system can provide
you with peace of mind and the ensure
assurance that you and your loved ones
will be well taken care of right now my
Patron Supply is knocking 200 off their
popular three-month emergency food kit
to help you start growing your supply go
to preparewithwalsh.com and grab the
special price before it ends your
three-month emergency food kit provides
over 2 000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in stressful
situations you can enjoy a wide variety
of my Patriot Supply food from
buttermilk pancakes chicken alfredo rice
pudding their meals have have you
covered for every part of your day the
best part is each meal is actually
delicious don't wait for disaster to
strike before taking action invest in
your safety and your well-being and that
of your family by securing your food
storage today go to preparewithwalsh.com
and save 200 on each kit that your
family needs go to prepare with
walsh.com right now that's prepare with
walsh.com
buying a new car can be a stressful
experience for anybody especially if
you're a first time buyer or you have no
credit before you walk into a dealership
and spend the entire day with the crowds
the stress the potential to not even
find the right car you need to check out
car zinc carzing is completely changing
the way you buy a car online by
partnering with Credit Agencies lenders
and over 25 000 dealers Nationwide
karzing provides you with everything you
need before stepping foot into a
dealership once you find the right car
at your ideal budget all you got to do
is bring your save deal voucher with you
to the dealership to finalize your next
ride it is so simple and even if you're
not in the market for a new car you
could check out carzing anyway karzing's
online window shopping experience goes
beyond mirror images you can dive deep
into each vehicle's specifications or
features their performance capabilities
zoom in on the craftsmanship of the
Interior Marvel at The Cutting Edge
technology and admire the meticulous
attention to detail that sets these
automobiles apart from the rest karzing
helps make your experience faster
cheaper less stressful visit carzing.com
Walsh today and find the best deal deals
near you that's karzing.com Walsh
given the scale of this operation you
might even say that this is a a great
replacement you aren't supposed to say
that of course but the truth is the
truth regardless
how big of a role is the decline in
testosterone playing in this well you'll
see a lot of news reports claiming that
it's not playing a role at all they're
saying people don't want children
anymore
but that's not really true as the UNC
Carolina population Center found this
year quote birth rates are falling in
the United States but it isn't because
Americans say they want fewer kids in
fact Young Americans haven't changed the
number of children they intend to have
in decades
which is very interesting
so the explanation is not that Human
Nature has changed Gallup wasn't wrong
all those years human beings still
fundamentally desire the same things
they always have
the explanation then has to be something
else if you go back to that ABC report
we just played they interview someone
who says that she has found the culprit
watch
Dr Swann says certain chemicals
pervasive in our environment are also
having an impact they're called
endocrine disrupting chemicals these
chemicals are found in products many of
us use every day from things like
Electronics to Plastics even cosmetics
and food packaging Dr Patricia hunt a
geneticist at Washington State
University studied their impact and
their prevalence the reason they're
called that is because they have the
ability to mimic or interfere with our
body's hormones these chemicals can
alter the formation of organs and organ
systems within the fetus
and change behavior and influence things
like our reproductive ability is it even
possible to avoid them or are they that
pervasive that it's kind of a foregone
conclusion it is impossible to avoid
them
so the explanation for declining sperm
counts according to that researcher in
the clip is that there are chemicals in
the products that are impossible to
avoid it's a foregone conclusion that
fertility is declining you just have to
accept it as the price you pay to live
in a modern society with things like
grocery stores and you know cell phones
and shampoo bottles
there's no need for personal
responsibility whatsoever it's just the
way things are we're told now to be fair
to that researcher there probably are
chemicals in many products that are
affecting male fertility we're ingesting
a lot of chemicals that we shouldn't be
ingesting and that's a problem in its
own right but as a complete explanation
for what we're seeing intuitively it
doesn't make the most sense
like it Remains the case that if you uh
even if you're eating what everybody
else is eating if you spend a lot of
time outside in the sun instead of
saying it's staying inside staring at a
screen all day you'll be more alert more
focused more engaged everyone knows that
that's because the sun stimulates your
pituitary gland releasing hormones that
stimulate testosterone production
so if we can have that kind of impact on
our testosterone levels just by going
outside
what else can we do
there's new research showing that
actually there is one simple trick that
more young men could try and should
if they want to preserve their
testosterone they can start by putting
down the porn
turning off the porn
putting the phone down altogether really
is a good start
and if our political leaders wanted to
take a serious step to increase
fertility rates by the same token they
could start passing laws to help free
the population especially the young male
population from the Stranglehold that
the porn industry has on it of course no
public health expert quote unquote in
America would ever run a study
supporting that conclusion So This
research comes from the journal
Frontiers and endocrinology where
researchers in China have put together
an article called pornography use could
lead to addiction and was associated
with reproductive hormone levels and
semen quality the researcher studied
hundreds of college students and they
separated the students who had exposure
to pornography in early adolescence
from those who hadn't and the study
found that quote early pornography
exposure was associated with lower adult
FSH
progesterone and prolactin levels in
serum and that's significant because
Normal prolactin levels are necessary to
maintain a normal level of testosterone
therefore as the researchers put it
quote pornography use at an early stage
may affect the function of the hpg
access and subsequently affect the
secretion of steroid hormones such as
estrogen Androgen prolactin and
progesterone eventually affecting semen
quality these effects were not temporary
the researchers found that quote earlier
contact to pornography might lead to the
disturbance of sexual hormone secretion
and therefore lead to lower sperm
concentration in adult semen this is one
of the many reasons that they ban
pornography in China so the question is
have you ever heard of this study
probably not because outside of the sun
and the New York Post which both
reported on study over the weekend it's
hard to find a single publication in any
country that's talking about the effects
of pornography on testosterone
production
no politician is saying a word about it
and again it's odd seeing as these
findings relate to an issue that 90 of
Americans care about which is fertility
not to mention Human Society
fundamentally depends on fertility in
order to increase in order to continue
existing so I'd say it's pretty
important for that reason alone
and it's not just porn there's good
reason to believe that any kind of
anti-social activity involving a screen
will have a negative impact on your body
we can assume that staring at social
media on your phone all day doesn't help
your testosterone levels either same for
sitting around and watching TV all day
binging Netflix playing video games or
whatever else
seems to be pretty intuitive
and for some reason medical experts
haven't made that connection
all the Senators and congressmen who
want to ban Tick Tock haven't made that
connection either but but it's obviously
there
the only real solution here lies not
with those politicians or public health
experts after all you know I've been far
too generous to these people by saying
that they haven't noticed the drop in
fertility rates and how it's connected
to rampant porn use or they don't care
about it and truth of course many of
them have noticed it and they're happy
about it
the system wants young people young men
in particular to be numb satiated
neutered
because men who are aware and proactive
men who uh go out and start families and
have lots of kids these men are threats
to the system
they're harder for the powers that be to
control
and they raise children who are the same
and that's why young men need to realize
that what they were told was just
mirrorless mere harmless distractions
were in fact hindering them at a
biological level
from doing what they most wanted in life
and now they have to pull themselves out
of the digital porn-laced fog that
they're in and live a real life with
real responsibilities and real
relationships that's the only antidote
and it means pursuing marriage and
family life and pursuing it early in
adulthood
the overwhelming majority of Americans
that's what they desire they've always
desired that
and contrary to what they've been told
over and over again they can still have
it that'll do it for this portion of
shows and move over to the members block
you can become a member today by using
Code walls to check out for two months
free on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed